we're going to
use an rnn and we're going to address a
different kind of
sequence
problem and this is time series
forecasting
so what you've seen here is three time
series
and these are financial time series and
they cover the period
1960 to 1990
okay and these are daily time series
daily meaning trade-in days so it's five
days a week five trading days a week
and in the top plot you see the log of
trade-in volume
in the middle plot you see the dow jones
return it's an index
and in the lower plot you see a measure
of volatility on that day
okay
and
the red line
is indicating we're going to use this
first part of the data for training a
model and we're going to test it out on
the on on the slightly grayed out
version of the data right so it's a
train in a test set
and this is important when you deal with
time series
because as you'll see the data are
autocorrelated so you can't just
randomly select some training days and
and test days
you need to sort of break apart time
like that
there's a period
i got it a little bit wrong
there's 6051 trading days
from 1962 to 1986.
so the log trading volume is a fraction
of all outstanding shares that are
traded on that day
relative to 100 day moving average of
past turnover on the log scale so it's a
definition this is a constructed
variable
dow jones return is just what it is this
is the difference between the log of the
dow jones industrial index on
consecutive trading days
that's where the word return comes from
the log volatility this is based on the
absolute values of the daily price
movements
so the goal here is to predict log
trading volume tomorrow given its
observed values up to today as well as
as observed values of the dow jones
return and the log volatility
and here we give a reference for these
data they were assembled by lebaron and
wagon
in
1998 and so you can find that reference
so it's interesting here we're going to
try and predict log trade in volume
that's something turns out is
you can do a reasonable job doing if you
had to try and predict the dow jones
return or stock prices that would be a
much much harder problem i'm just going
to ask you whether you could help me to
improve the yield on my portfolio
are you the right person to ask for this
rob i'm the absolute worst problem to
ask in fact if you ask me what you could
do is is moving the other direction
maybe i'll try it
so here's the log trade-in volume
and what we're showing here is what's
known as the autocorrelation function
at different lags
so what you the autocorrelation function
does is the following
v is the index is the variable we we
that we call in a log trading volume
and
we've got we look at pairs v t and v t
minus l
so that means they had a lag of l
trading days apart right so imagine all
the pairs you could get like that in in
the data set
and we take those pairs and compute the
correlation
of those pairs of numbers and that's
called the order correlation of lag l
and here we show the auto correlations
of lag 1 2 3 4 and so on
and you can see
so
the log trading volume
has a correlation
of
0.7
between values today and values
yesterday
that's lag one
not much lower between values two days
apart right so that
that's that's what's known as
autocorrelation and when you look at a
series
that's kind of what you see in here you
know it does it's not chaotic this looks
much more chaotic the the dow jones
return
but the trade-in volume it tends to go
up for a while come down for a while
there's a lot of noise
but
that those sort of small trends that you
see is a reflection of this auto
correlation okay
so these sizeable correlations give us
confidence that past values will be
helpful in predicting the future
and this is a curious prediction problem
because the response is vt we want to
predict the log trading volume at a
particular time t but it's also going to
be part of the features we're going to
use values
of that same sequence that lags back to
predict
the value at vt
so it's fair game to use values of the
series from earlier days to predict into
the future so let's see how we set this
up for a recurrent neural network
we only have one series of data
so how do we set up an rnn
so what we do
is we first of all decide on the number
the lag the number of lags we're going
to use which we call earlier and in our
example we're going to use a lag of five
okay
and we're going to make extract many
short mini series of input sequences
and they're going to be of the form x1
x2 up to xl and remember if
l is going to be 5 here
and what is going to be
in these elements
well here they are
so
we're using v
r for the for the dow jones return and z
for the volatility
and so remember we need a sequence of
length five here or of length l so
they're going to be
v t minus l r t minus l z t minus l
those three numbers
that's going to be the first element in
the sequence the second
is going to be
so that's at lag five if l is five then
we're going to get those so same three
numbers that lag
four back leg three back up to lag one
back
okay so that's how we make the sequence
but of course
you get these five
three vectors if you start at time t
if you go to a different time you get a
different set of three vectors
so the number of observations are the
number of time points
the features are these lagged versions
of the of the three series
and the response is the log volatility
at the particular time
so we have
six thousand and fifty one trading days
and with lu5 equals 5 we can turns out
we can create
6046 such x y
pairs
and by x here we mean x is a sequence
right
and a sequence of three vectors
and it's slightly less because
obviously right at the beginning we
can't lag back because there's nothing
you know there's nothing to like to
so we just truncate
and we use the first
4281 as training data and the following
1770 as test data that's the shaded
parts in the in those
initial images
and we're going to fit a recurrent
neural network with 12 hidden units per
lag step
ie per ao so each al will be a vector of
12 units
this is a picture
of the log trading volume for the test
period
and the black is the observed
and the orange is the predicted from the
rnn
and it looks pretty good to me
hey rob yeah
it's it's a little shorter doesn't get
the highest peaks or the lowest dips but
it pretty much follows the sequence you
can see that
the r squared is 0.42 on the on the test
data
one way of comparing that is an r
squared of
0.18 for a straw man
straw man is sort of the natural
competitor in this case that's easy to
compute
and the straw man we use is we're going
to use yesterday's value of log trading
volume to predict that of today
right that should be pretty good right
because of that auto correlation
so we don't expect the straw mania to be
useful useless
but it gets an r squared of of 0.18 and
we can do considerably better using an
rnn
now
since we've gone into this example we're
going to tell you about
another way of doing forecasting using a
very similar structure and that's known
as auto regression and this is just
using linear models okay
so
the structure is the same you set up a
data set
and we'll first use the response itself
which is the log trade-in volume
and
you create a data set where you have a
sequence of the responses
it goes up to v capital t and goes all
the way down and we go back to lag l
plus one because we we need to create
lag variables and we can't go further
back than that
and then we build up a model matrix
we've got an intercept we've got the
you know so for each say vt
we've got a vt minus one it's going to
be a feature a vt minus two is a feature
up to vt minus l
and then
if you go to the next
time point back
right
you'll get the same things but
one time step back
until eventually
the response vlm plus 1 has features vl
vl minus 1 up to
down to v1 so this is a traditional
autoregression setup where you just got
one sequence and you're using lagged
versions of that sequence to predict the
response
but of course we can augment this matrix
with lagged versions of the the logged
out jones return
and the volatility measure as well
so if you look back this is a very
similar data structure to which was used
for the rnn
but now what we do is just a plain
linear regression we do a linear
regression
of
this response set of response numbers
using this data matrix to make our
predictions
and this is known as an order
autoregression model or arl
so yes we'll have if we got lags say
five we're gonna have three l plus one
columns
because we've got three different
variables and the interhip is the
additional one
okay we'll just tell you some results
here so for the a or 5 model we get an r
squared of 0.41
and it's got 16 parameters
3 times 5 plus 1.
the rnn that we described earlier as an
r squared of 0.42 slightly better
with 205 parameters
many more parameters this is this is a
repeating story with neural networks you
can have lots more parameters
and you don't pay much in terms of
overfitting because of the way they fit
and regularized you can take this
structure for the the aor model and
instead of fitting a linear model you
can just fit it through a feed forward
neural network
okay and when we did that we get the
same
performance as the rnn
you can add another variable which turns
out to be really informative for log
trading volume which is the day of the
week was it a monday tuesday
or fridays right and that turns out that
all the models improve and you can get
an r squared of 0.46
okay
so that's the end of autoregression
two examples one using an rnn one using
more standard uh statistical model
a little bit different in in structure
performance
somewhat similar
so to summarize um
rnns so we've presented the simplest of
rnn's there are many more
complex variations that exist
one variation treats
the sequence as a one-dimensional image
and uses cnns for fitting
for example a sequence of words using an
embedding representation can be viewed
as an image and the cnn convolves by
sliding a con convolutional filter along
the sequence so it's like a
one-dimensional convolutional filter
you can have additional hidden layers
where each hidden layer is a sequence
and feeds into the next hidden layer
and you can also have output be a
sequence
and input and output share the hidden
units
so there's something called a seek to
seek learning and and they're used for
language translation so for example the
input data is a sequence of words in an
english document
and the output sequences this the same
words translated into german
you've got input is a sequence the
output is a sequence
and there's many more so it's a it's a
rich area and and there's lots of
recurrent neural networks out there
again one can have access to these
okay so we've talked of a number of
neural networks
networks for images networks for
sequences
networks for just general data
and the question is when to use deep
learning so cnns have had enormous
success in in image classification
and modeling
and they're starting to be used in in
medical diagnosis so examples include
digital mammography ophthalmology mri
scans and digital x-rays
and we talked briefly about using
pre-trained images to be feature
extractors
for examples like this where you don't
have that much training data
rnans have had big wins in speech
modeling language translation and
forecasting
so the question is should we always use
deep learning models
it seems they have the capability of
taking over any kind of of modeling
often the big successes occur
when the signal to noise ratio is high
so what we mean by that is for example
in image recognition and language
translation
humans can can classify images almost
perfectly
especially natural images
that means that
the information in the input
image is enough to get the the target
exactly so the signal is there's a lot
of thing very little noise
the same is true for language
translation
you've got large data sets and
overfitting is not such a problem in
cases like that
because overfitting means fitting the
noise and so if there's not much noise
it's not going to be a problem with
human populations trying to predict
whether someone's going to respond to a
drug based on their genetic profile for
example this
single noise ratio is often very low yes
because there's so much noise in right
human populations yeah
that's right
and you know a lot of the data sets rob
and i see in for example in the medical
school they to do with human populations
and can be very noisy right
so for noisier data simpler models can
can often work better
so on the new york stock exchange data
that's somewhat noisy data the ar5 model
is is much simpler than a rnn and
performed as well
and on the imdb review data the linear
model fit by glimnet did as well as as a
neural network and and better than the
the rnn
granted there's more sophisticated rnn's
now that can do a bit better but a lot
of work to for
quite small gains in that case
so we endorsed the occam's razor
principle
we prefer simpler models if they work as
well say more interpretable yeah
i think also remember i think the
successes we've seen with neural
networks in this lecture for example
that the the um
the inputs have certain have come on
some kind of temporal or spatial
structure right the in the images
of course there's there's a structure in
the image in the uh time series examples
or the speeches that the uh
in the the movie review there's
structure in the inputs right there's a
time ordering and neural networks have
have the capability to model that kind
of structure yeah
that's right
and of course the creators of neural
networks and the people who work in it
now are very creative in adapting to new
kinds of data structures right so the
nice thing about neural network is it's
actually it's kind of a toolbox where
you can you can tailor the
uh
the network structure to the the things
you know about the problem so it's a
very uh
very rich way of modeling